I can't think of a moment bigger than
this one
I've likened this as the moment for
biology akin to the moment when fissile
nuclear material was figured out by
physics and offered both a way to solve
the problems of the universe and nuclear
weapons
these papers really represent a seminal
moment in life sciences we now really
have been confronted with examples of
where the science itself which is very
important and moving forward for the
public's health also pose a potential
risk for nefarious actions or in even
those situations where this virus might
escape from a laboratory so we're really
at a point for the first time of trying
to balance the need to know versus the
need to protect there is a need for dual
use research that's the that's the point
for establishing of this committee the
NSABB and the idea there is that we find
some way to balance public health
interests freedom of speech and freedom
to research of scientists with the
public good and public concerns about
the safety and security of research
we believe that it would be not in the
world's best interest to have all the
detailed information come out now having
said that we also have made a very
strong call for an international
discussion about where do we go forward
so the NSABB never saw itself as being
the final arbiter on this really where I
think you might say the first Court of
Appeals and we know we need more
guidance from all the Life Sciences
around the world to move to the next
step I think we can learn a great deal
about transmission of influenza virus
through the air from this work this is a
question we know very little about there
are very very few systems in which to
study it and these are the first
advances that we have on studying the
transmission in ferrets so there's so
many additional experiments that come
from this it would be a shame to
suppress the data from these these
experiments
one of the really disappointing parts of
this discussion to date has been that
everyone seems to have their own set of
facts and in particular for myself
coming from a public health background
where I've been in the trenches fighting
disease doing surveillance stopping
outbreaks
I've watched a number of the life
scientists who have made blanket
statements about the public health
utility of this kind of information or
what we can do with it as a argument for
why it should be widely disseminated and
in the first instance none of this holds
water and it doesn't mean that the work
isn't important it doesn't mean life
sciences shouldn't move forward but
there's been a lot of misunderstandings
about what the real utility of this
information is and protecting the
public's health I think we need to have
an Asilomar type moment where scientists
meet and decide how to go forward
unfortunately since 9/11 we now have a
lot of policy analysts who are
participating in this debate not
scientists and I think it's unfortunate
in a way because this the result of
Asilomar where there were largely
scientists meeting where the regulation
is that applied to a comment DNA so in
ideal world that's what I would like to
happen but as you know it's not an ideal
world the mistake made at the Asilomar
moment was that it was scientists
talking to scientists very heated it was
not a you know happy little let's all
hold hands and agree and then saying to
the public
okay we've reached an agreement you all
should trust us and the backlash from
community to community all over the
world was enormous
after you've pursued work
there are lots of resources and trying
to get it done and you've submitted for
publication and be told that it can't be
published it would be far better to have
discussions of this sort at the time
that the work is first described
everybody can be a Monday Morning
Quarterback and say we should have
thought of this we could have thought of
this and we actually did we just didn't
think that influenza was the one we had
to worry about but now where we're at
those days are over with we now realize
we have to be very concerned about how
we move forward now my view I can't
think of an experiment done by a
legitimate scientist seeking answers to
a question that you wouldn't want to
publish I can think of very many
experiments that a nefarious scientist
would do and you wouldn't want to
publish and they wouldn't either but
legitimate experiments invite my view
are all publishable the issues about
publication and about conducting this
research really need to be addressed by
the scientific community at large with
representatives from public health with
international representation I think
it's very important that this debate
appears now and I think these papers
have given us the opportunity to have
this debate now